ces centrales nucléaires allemandes
vivent leurs dernières heures ce
vendredi ce sont trois réacteurs qui ont
été fermées soit la moitié du parc du
pays discutait depuis plusieurs années
est entérinée après la catastrophe de
fukushima en 2011 la sortie du nucléaire
entre donc dans sa dernière ligne droite
fin 2022 ce sera au tour des trois
dernières centrales du pays d'être
définitivement retirée du réseau le
démantèlement des bâtiments devrait lui
prendre plusieurs années
le processus de déclassement et de
démantèlement prend du temps parce qu'il
ya aussi de nombreuses questions de
sécurité à considérer si les travaux se
passe bien nous pourrons commencer le
démantèlement à partir de 2023 ensuite
la plus grande partie le stockage des
composants radioactifs sera bientôt
achevée mais il faudra plusieurs
décennies avant que le bâtiment ne soit
plus visible
en deux décennies l'allemagne aura fermé
35 unités nucléaires un processus
poursuivi est achevée par olaf scholz
lors de ses voeux le nouveau chancelier
a d'ailleurs dévoilé ses ambitions
énergétique l'allemagne devrait être
climatiquement neutre dans moins de 25
ans pour ce faire nous ferons progresser
la plus grande restructuration de notre
économie depuis plus de 100 ans pendant
cette période nous nous rendrons
indépendant du charbon du pétrole et du
gaz et en même temps produire au moins
deux fois plus d'électricité
qu'aujourd'hui à partir du vent du
soleil et d'autres énergies
renouvelables une tâche gigantesque
mais avant d'atteindre cet objectif le
pays se fournit massivement combustibles
fossiles
un pari qui est un coup en pleine crise
énergétique en europe les cours du gaz
se sont envolés tandis que les énergies
renouvelables ne compense pas encore le
manque
autre conséquence pour l'allemagne du
recours aux combustibles fossiles
l'alourdissement probable des émissions
de co2 en france la question du
nucléaire est également sur la table de
la campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron à d'ores et déjà annoncé
vouloir réinvestir dans le secteur